foreign
Mark of the year and I think it's pretty
fun to shake things up a bit and to do
something that I haven't done before so
today I'll be listing down what I
personally think are the top 10 shows so
far in 2023 these are my personal takes
and while we may have different
selections on our rankings if you
haven't watched anything from this year
then you could use this list as a
reference on a possible show to pick up
let's start with blade of the Guardians
all right
what sets blade of the Guardians apart
is its jaw-dropping action scenes
seriously these battles are the bomb the
animation is so slick and stylish it'll
have you jumping out of your seat with
excitement from epic displays of
strength to lightning fast combos the
fights in Blade of the Guardians are
like a visual Symphony of martial arts
goodness you'll be left wide-eyed and
cheering for more guarantee but it's not
all about the punches in the feels the
Chinese animation also explores some
seriously cool themes so folks there you
have it blade of the Guardians is one
hell of an anime that's taken 2023 by
storm with its Kick-Ass action lovable
characters and Powerful messages it's
earned its spot amongst the best of the
best
with the awesome mobile devices that we
have to watch these shows on in the best
quality possible how about taking it a
step further with this awesome game yes
I'm talking about the sponsors of this
video rage Shadow Legends I'm sure a lot
of you have heard of this game but what
is it really about it's a game that puts
you in the role of a resurrected Warrior
looking to take down the Dark Lord that
rules over the realm of Talaria sure a
pretty engaging story but wait till you
see the gameplay this game lets you
engage in strategic battles that will
keep you hooked for days personally I'm
more of a sucker for the collectible
aspects of mobile games and coming up
with some underrated synergies between
my favorite team members thankfully with
the amount of Champions the game has and
the sheer number of customization
options I found those Cravings satisfied
now's a good time to hop onto it too
after all a limited event featuring the
hit series call of the Arbiter is well
underway it's also headlined by the free
legendary champion Art Attack all you
have to do is log in for a total of
seven days from now until July the 24th
and you'll get to add our tag to your
collection on the other hand there's
nothing more frustrating a new player
then to get wall down to progress early
on so check out this starter pack that
will help you in that part of the
journey just use my link or scan the QR
code and get started on your quest to
defeat the dark lord my number nine spot
we may have a surprise pick as I go for
Trigun stampede
you've been checking out this channel
for a while you'll know that I like
Trigun in its original Incarnation
that's why I was super excited when
Stampede got announced and when it aired
I got something that was on par with my
expectations the secret to enjoying
Trigun Stampede is similar to how I look
at Ruby's ice queen Dem it's never going
to be the ultimate remake sequel or new
anime that's going to match the original
Trigun those instances are extremely
rare however what Stampede brings to the
table more than satisfied my thirst for
something Trigun in the 2020s it's been
a familiar yet different experience
watching Stampede and I actually think
that it Compares rather favorably to the
original Trigun it feels a lot more
character focused giving us a similar
Taste of the old one with a new flavor
and it isn't anything to scoff out on
the production side of things either
this is a welcome addition to the
library for you to ask me
up next we have Heavenly delusion
[Music]
and it could be recency bias and all but
Heavenly delusion has impressed me so
far it's something that I almost glossed
over when doing the seasonal preview for
spring but I'm sure as hell I'm glad
that I did him checking this out it has
an atmosphere that you don't get to see
every day in anime people have compared
it to something like promise Neverland
sunny boy along with the last of us and
I'm pretty inclined to agree it's a show
that really makes you keep watching with
the mystery and layers of questions that
are thrown at you Heavenly delusion
really thrives on its atmosphere setting
and the occasional action that keeps
things fast and heated all this
complemented with excellent art and
sound direction to capture the perfect
Ambiance for a story set in a world like
this I didn't expect it to go mainstream
but for those who are into this genre
Heavenly delusion is something that you
may not want to miss
thank you
hell's Paradise takes you on an
adventure to remember
so coming into spring 2023 one of the
shows I was most excited for was hell's
Paradise I had high hopes for it and I
feel that it could be the next big thing
in the world has shown him while I
didn't see the expected cultural impact
just yet people have responded hell's
Paradise is currently one of the more
popular shows from Spring 2023 and it's
not hard to see why you know sure the
plot's something that's obviously not
meant for those looking for super mature
philosophical takes on the world and the
meaning of life but among Shonen titles
it does a really great job in character
writing and it's really fun to learn
more about these convicts as The Show
Goes On they all have their goals and
are easy to root for as they each carry
their own charms most importantly they
work well together and are such a joy to
watch in their respective fight scenes
if you're a fan of action adventure and
Anime fights hell's Paradise is a must
watch especially since it's a new anime
that you can easily pick up from the
start and I'm pretty positive we'll be
getting more of it in the future
[Applause]
right before the halfway mark we put the
spotlight on Dr Stone New World
[Music]
doctor stones come a pretty long way
hasn't it if there's a story that's all
about the joy of exploration backed with
a wonderful world that you want to keep
seeing then this is it granted there
have been a couple of shows that have
adventure and exploration as its focus
Dr Stone however has a more scientific
approach to it and I'd say that it's
worked out wonderfully well so far with
how much I enjoyed Stone Wars a part of
me did feel sad to leave that side of
the story and move on to new world but
mostly I feel that new world showcases
the beauty of a story that can be
expanded as much as Dr Stone can
shifting through Focus points seamlessly
is something that will always impress me
with an anime it's the same show got the
same characters and has the same
overarching theme however the shift in
approach and source of overall tension
is a great indicator of the style Dr
Stone uses for its story progression
still if this is the third season I'm
talking about and rather than talking
more about this season I'd recommend
checking this out from the start after
all Dr Stone feels like a show that you
can't just hop into and enjoy fully it's
something that's all about the journey
instead of the hype of the moment
foreign
[Music]
we then proceed to the newest season of
Demon Slayer because why not
there's no denying how much of a mark
Dimas slayer's made in the anime
Community since the end of the last
decade and there's no reason to think
that UFO table would let up after seeing
the franchise break records left and
right that momentum carried on to this
newest season one that I admittedly
didn't have as much height for his
Infinity train or Entertainment District
Arc as a source reader still swordsmith
Village is an integral part of the story
it's got a lot of moments to remember
all while putting the spotlight on the
pillars that needed a lot of shine if
you've watched any of the previous
seasons of Demon Slayer you already know
what to expect by the time you pick up
this latest season pretty colors insane
animation basically top-notch production
that's quickly becoming the norm in
modern Shonen Blockbusters I'd say that
it's placed here pretty high because it
still does a great job entertaining me
however I don't see demons there
breaking any new ground with this right
to your characterization still does it
have to when its main appeal has always
been the fights the moments to keep you
on the edge of your seats and the
characters who get to show off every
other episode I'd look for Demon Slayer
to keep up with the momentum all the way
to a cinematic finish as we approach the
home stretch
for my fourth rank title we have bungo
stray dogs 4.
from one of the biggest Shonen in the
past five years to what I'd call an
underrated Saiyan even in the smaller
library in the genre Bongo stray dogs
has consistently been a fan favorite in
Japan but the reception just hasn't been
the same level overseas I'll say that
you're all missing out on one of the
best actions saying and out there bungo
stray dogs continues to prove its worth
Four Seasons in and when I personally
had a lot of memorable moments from the
previous Seasons the fourth one simply
ramps up the intensity the stakes feel a
lot higher than before and it seems that
the Thrills and suspense have been up
big time there's more character
development and while I personally feel
that few can match the hype of the main
hero and his rival taking on the villain
at the end of the second season the
fourth season of bungo stray dogs has
shaped up to the sequel that lives up to
its predecessors bungo stray dogs
continues to prove to be a diamond in
the rough a gem that people haven't had
the pleasure to experience as much it's
not a completely new show but I feel it
deserves more love than what I'm seeing
foreign
opening the top three is oshinoko
there's no doubt that one of if not the
biggest anime phenomenon in 2023 belongs
to the list coming from the same guy who
gave us the Smash Hit gaguya Sama comes
this title where things take a way
darker turn oshinoko probably had so
much hype entering the season and the
anime team made sure it lived up to it
even exceeding expectations in a lot of
ways there's a lot of love and care
being put on this show from the movie
length opening episode to the huge
marketing push on social media that went
all in on oshinoko and I think there's
no show that deserves it more than this
one there's a lot to be said about how
well the show does in the production
department but I always look at oshinoko
more for its thematic value sure if
we're going to be cynical and critical
we can see that the whole criticism of
the entertainment industry as well as
looking at parasocial relationships in
societies nothing new so I don't think
that any modern anime has handled it in
a way that hits as hard as it does in
oshinoko perhaps it's because of the
characters that you can't help but care
about or perhaps it's because of the
whole crime thread a premise the show
had to hook people in maybe because
there's just the whole level of gravity
in which the show looks at these dark
sides of Showbiz matters oshinoko is
definitely one of the strongest hits
this year and it more than deserves the
praise it's been garnering I won't Crown
it new anime of the year just yet but
it's certainly made a very strong case
make sure you go and watch this one
[Music]
Dorito
things
following year is the latest season of
Attack on Titan
a decade that's how long it's been since
the world was introduced to this epic
series known as Attack on Titan and
since then it's taken us through a lot
of twists and turns from the high
tension and Bleak opening Seasons to
what we have now I'd say the attack on
Titan has shown as the best of several
worlds with how long it's been it's hard
to talk about the latest season in
detail but I say that throughout these
years Attack on Titan has remained
consistent in tone and production
excellent even with the change in studio
it's a show that always brings you in
with the action the breathtaking fights
before making you stay with the
questions the Mysteries that make you
second guess what you know about
Humanity it's a modern Masterpiece a
decade ago and I'm going to say that if
you're one of the labs fans who only
watched the first few parts coming back
and joining the ride again isn't such a
bad proposition the hype may have faded
from The Glory Days but the Journey's
still nothing short of amazing the same
still holds true now they're in the
climax of the entire thing most fans are
probably fully aware of the
controversial nature of its manga ending
but I'm more excited as we move towards
the home stretch I really look forward
just seeing how the anime will handle
[Music]
that's my top anime of 2023 so far
Vinland Saga season two
I've always been very high on Finland
Saga I loved it for how complete it is
as a product you've got the action the
character development the nice plot
progression the meaningful story beats
the captivating world and so forth I'm
glad to say that the same holds true for
this season of Finland Saga despite the
DraStic shift in tone a lot of times
when a series departs from its initial
turn in a way as drastic as this one it
does end up being off-putting I mean
this is just what Finland Saga is now no
longer the violent and lost field
Adventures through the treacherous world
but a drama that's considerably slower
and pacing I'd still say that the magic
is still there and I say that because I
know that villain saga's greatest
strength is getting you immersed in its
World building and characterization it
may no longer be the battle through the
high seas but there's still a whole new
world to explore out there and more
characters to learn about now the
spotlight Shines on torfin as a war
veteran and a focus on what living means
to people in this era not a lot of shows
can do the genre shift as well as
Finland Saga did how it manages to pull
it off earns it top spot in my favorite
anime of 2023 is far as June goes
[Music]
and that ends my list I'd appreciate
hearing what you have to say about it
that's why you should leave it all down
in the comments and what you think are
the best shows we've gotten so far once
again thank you rage Shadow Legends for
sponsoring today's video use my link in
the description or scan the QR code and
get started on your raid Journey now
with that I thank you for watching and I
hope to see you next time